welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 will Air episodes
on Thursdays at 9pm Eastern 6 p.m
Pacific an announcement made through new
promo footage with new looks at Loki
Sophie Kang OB and Miss minutes with her
creepy little phrases as always just
watch y'all know I'm obsessed with this
show I scrutinize every detail and
everything I can find for it and Loki
season 2 with its finale that'll come
sometime around Thanksgiving will be the
last Marvel title I get to dive into
before I become a dad this holiday
season so it's gonna be flavored with
the fear that I'll forget something and
the anxiety that I'm gonna mess
everything up but let's break this down
before I break down okay let's check out
this September 18th amazing Loki behind
the scenes featurette it's go time day
one
I'm excited to be back
back of the TVA
everything is stepped up again the steps
are huge get to see Tom in a suit
a lot of people are gonna like that we
introduced this whole new corner to the
MCU and these new characters
I've been a fan of the Marvel Universe
for a long time I'm so grateful to be a
part of this amazing series rest assured
our Loki will be with our Mobius and
they will be dealing with the
consequences of this first season a
little over the top don't you think I
thought it was spot on
2 is about low-key understanding himself
Loki who's always been a villain what we
want to explore is also Loki finding
what heroicism really looks like
we're playing God we are Gods he's found
a new family there's a new capacity to
make connections what is it that you
really want I want to save my friends he
realizes that those connections are all
that matter in the end
[Music]
be here all week
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Behind These clapboards there is a
scene in the time court that has the
orange mural that Loki points to in the
other season 2 promo shot it looks like
this might be episode 1 scene 14c
there's also the scene with the yellow
TVA mail truck crashed into the Chrono
monitor station where Casey works with
the orange rounded TV monitor that
crashes down in a shower Sparks this
looks like it's episode 1 scene four
from the clapboard actually a later shot
shows Loki in the back of that truck
this is part of the Season 2 opening
sequence shown at d23 which picks up
with the ending of Loki season 1 as Loki
leaps from that TVA level past the
statue of Kang that looms over it all
and lands in this yellow mail truck but
this truck has a Mis minutes bumper
sticker housed by driving report made to
294-x3xv657890x7 so it's not call this
number it's literally report me too and
it might be crazy but the driver of this
truck has short blonde hair kind of like
Sofia dimartino in the promo shots from
this same featurette this might be
Sylvie because the d23 version of the
scene implied that this is all happening
when Loki time slipped into a past
version of the TVA when Kang still ruled
over it openly before he decided to
reset everything so that he was hiding
behind the timekeepers and who knows
maybe in that past era of the TVA Sylvie
had tried to infiltrate it or decided to
stay working as atva male delivery
person now this driver is miked so
they're gonna have a line here they're
not just the background character since
I am revisiting each episode of season
one in our Loki recap series that you
should definitely check out if you go
back to rewatch episode 3 lamentis
Sylvie said that she fell in love with a
postal Courier managed to maintain quite
a serious long-distance relationship
with a postman whilst running across
time from one apocalypse to another now
we have speculated that that postal
mystery lover could be Willie Loken the
Marvel mailman played by Stan Lee in
2005's Fantastic Four or even Dennis the
mailman from One Division but since OB
is the receiver of all pneumatic tubes
correspondence in the TBA maybe he was
the one that she fell in love with but
also the driver of this mail truck might
actually be Kate Dickey's character
who's still an unknown but back in
February she was rumored to be playing
quote an evil General who wants her
soldiers former TVA agents to destroy
the new timelines created after the
death of he who remains it would just be
kind of fun to have such an important
figure established early on as a poster
worker in an old era of the TBA someone
who would have later on Gone Postal and
broken away from the TBA leading other
former variants up against it from the
void I do like the idea that she's
playing an older Sylvie variant to
initially play ball with the TVA but
then betrayed it like the silviest
Sylvie you could say anyway the editing
of this trailer also includes a frame
segmented into 12 wedges assembling
clockwise like the 12 numbers of a clock
from what I can tell these are all Loki
from other trailer shots we've seen
already but the four o'clock position
shows Loki in that Corona monitor
station with Sylvie behind him it looks
like Loki after reuniting with Sylvie
after the events of season one when
she's working as a McDonald's employee
brings her back into the TVA there is a
new shot of Jonathan Majors as Victor
timely looks like he's on the platform
for the loading Booth of the ferris
wheel at the 1893 World's Fair later we
see Victor blasted out of this structure
by Loki sorcery which seems to follow
with Mobius covering for Loki by telling
all these Victorian Chicagoans the
amazing lokia
remember how old cell phones were giant
cumbersome bricks and now we have nice
Sleek ones that fit easily in our
pockets well wallets are the same way so
say goodbye to your bulky wallet of
yesteryear and say hello to ridge ridge
has reinvented the wallet and it is a
massive improvement over the ginormous
overstuffed wallets that we all grew up
with the ridge wallet is slim but
expands to hold up to 12 cards plus cash
Ridge wallets come in over 30 colors and
styles including carbon fiber burnt
titanium forged Ember and burnt Damascus
each wallet is built with RFID blocking
materials that protect your info from
digital pickpockets and adds an optional
air tag attachment so you'll never lose
your wallet again Bridge has 80 000 5
Star reviews and each wallet comes with
a lifetime warranty the rich team is so
confident that you'll like your wallet
that they'll let you test drive it for
99 days and if you don't love it send it
back for a full refund and from now
until it's September 30th with every
dollar spent on the website before
you'll be entered to win a brand new
upgraded Ford Bronco or if you prefer
cash you could take 75 000 instead the
winner will be announced in October
enter for your chance to win and get 10
bonus entries by going to MyLink
ridge.com new rockstars and use my code
new rockstars for 10 off your order now
there is a new angle of the movie actor
Brad wolf at the movie premiere for
zaniac and I just realized he has a date
in the car now this town car is black
but in other shots from past trailers
the wide shot of this movie premiere in
front of the theater there is a bright
orange car sitting in front of the
theater that could be how like B15 and
Sylvia Loki get to this location a car
the color of his minutes we see ob's
arrival in the TVA repairs office which
is quite an entrance reminded me of
galinda and Productions of wicked
suspended from a seat high above and he
passes this Tangled Thicket of pneumatic
tubes that all snake down into one Bunch
visually it's kind of like a vertical
version of the Tangled mess of the
Sacred timeline strands being woven down
in one coil and we actually see that
image in the backdrop of this viewing
station is Loki and Obi look out at it
but above their heads is this new detail
some kind of dial or sphere with a red
needle and black needles measuring maybe
relative stability I wonder if this
could be connected to the handheld meter
that Loki holds in other shots we've
seen there are some wholesome shots of
the cast hugging on set probably scenes
where kihui Kwan and Owen Wilson wrapped
for the season as that's usually when
the crew claps like this but one new
shot that freaks me out is this one all
over the top don't you think I thought
it was spot on we actually saw the same
shot back in the July trailer watch that
version of it a little over the top
don't you think other spot on
did he catch the difference now in this
promo the background behind Loki when he
says spot on has been augmented to add a
bunch of people in costume standing
frozen in the street maybe they were
filmed before but they were scrubbed out
of that July trailer for some reason but
it must mean that this shot was still
being edited in July or Marvel Studios
does not want us to see these people to
focus too much on them yet who are these
people they don't look like crew because
they look like they're in costume
there's someone in a white lab coat the
guy closest to us has shorter pants that
kind of look like the style worn during
Victorian times kind of looks like
Victor timely's costume I don't know
this is crazy my misminute's horrifying
truth video posted theory that the TVA
was created by Victor timely and Miss
minutes extracting the 1893 World's Fair
from the timeline replaced him with the
one that we know of in our timeline and
building the origins of the TVA on that
World's Fair architecture the temporal
Marvel that he shows off at that World's
Fair is the first building block of what
eventually becomes a TBA that's my
theory so if those people were displaced
from time maybe they ended up frozen in
the street outside the 70s movie
premiere in London now there is a shot
of the damage temporal core and an orb
of some kind at the end of the walkway
is this orb Ms minutes the OG Ms minutes
one that's not a sentient hologram of
temporal radiation or whatever it is
because when Mobius hops out of this
platform the entrance on the wall behind
him from the perspective of the walkway
reads four all time always why would you
need that on the outside of the building
in this temporal core that no one really
should be in without protective gear if
something isn't always there at the end
of that walkway to read and reflect on
that statement really though I think the
sweetest thing of this promo is this
little moment he's found a new family
there's a new capacity to make
connections what is it that you really
want I want to save my friends he
realizes that those connections are all
that matter in the end Loki and Sylvia
are going to have this moment in a bar
pool table jukebox behind them but on
the word friends we cut to this shot of
Loki looking back at B15 Mobius Casey
Sylvian OB these are Loki's friends now
who no longer cares about anyone who's
still in the sacred timeline he just
really relates to the other variants
like him who are alienated from time
itself just as he is feature it ends
with Loki flickering through various
backgrounds kind of looking like
Michelle yo in the Multiverse Montage of
everything everywhere all at once also
starring kiwi Kwan but one of those
backgrounds is definitely the 1982
McDonald's that Sylvie works at the
final new footage that I want to leave
you with is the premiere date
announcement clip hey y'all check this
out Loki returns
October 5th we're back great Loki season
two streaming October 5th at 6 PM PT
just watch I only single this out
because the final shot is definitely
miss minutes from a different moment
mouthing something completely different
with Tara Strong's voice just dubbing
over at the words just watch just watch
now another reminder that I explored
some other mysteries from Loki season 1
like what Quantum ore is in my Loki Deep
dive video on the Deep dive Channel
please subscribe to that and our channel
the break room and this channel new
rockstars you can follow me on all
social platforms at EA boss follow new
rockstars and brace yourself for the
craziest and most in-depth breakdowns of
Loki on YouTube starting October 5th bye
y'all
[Music]
thank you